enslaved land un barrio pobre de la
capital de sri lanka vive en milton y su
familia como muchos otros en el país no
tienen cómo comprar comida
es muy difícil vivir hasta el pan es
caro tenemos seis hijos en la familia
tenemos que saltarnos comidas si tenemos
una comida nos saltamos otra es muy
difícil
con una crisis económica que perdura
desde hace meses si la ncaa sufre de una
escasa es catastrófica de carburantes
medicamentos y otros productos
esenciales la inflación de los precios
de los alimentos alcanzó un 80 por
ciento en los últimos 12 meses stri
lanka dejó de pagar su deuda según el
programa alimentario mundial el 22 por
ciento de la población del país necesita
una ayuda alimentaria
la gente viene a comprar comida pero no
está contenta porque no tiene dinero los
precios han subido la razón principal es
que no hay forma de transportar estos
productos porque no hay combustible por
eso los precios han subido
la caída de la economía llevó a decenas
de miles de personas en las calles
durante semanas y tuvo como consecuencia
la dimisión del presidente rajapaksa no
obstante el movimiento no paro
hoy es el centésimo día de nuestra lucha
eliminar la maldición política de los
últimos 75 años eliminar la corrupción
la opresión y todas las formas de
explotación
que debe ser el parlamento ahora tiene
que nominar a un nuevo presidente y
anunció que el voto tendrá lugar este
miércoles